الى موضوع يهم الكثيرين ممن يبحثون عن
وظيفه جديده ويستعدون لمقابله عمل وين
بتروحين
[ضحك]
مشاهدينا يجب التجهيز جيدا للاسئله
المتوقعه متوقعه من قبل مسؤول التوظيف لكن
النصيحه الاهم هنا هي الاسئله التي يطرحها
طالب الوظيفه خلال المقابله مش العكس
بالتاكيد موقع يقدم نصيحه مهمه في ظل
تباطؤ التوظيف وهي ان تحديد عدد من
الاسئله لكي لا يظهر هذا المتقدم للوظيفه
ضعيفا او متسولا لهذه الوظيفه يعني ياخذها
هذه الاسئله يجب انها تطرح بادب هذا شيء
ضروري جدا وبشكل يدل على الاهتمام بمعرفه
الحقوق وايضا الواجبات ومنها سيتشكل
انطباع اذا كانت بيئه العمل الجديده صحيه
او غير ذلك خلينا نستعرض امثله على هذه
الاسئله في الشرح التالي مع زميلنا على
سرحان علاء
في مقابله العمل طرح الاسئله على مسؤول
التوظيف لا يميزك عن المرشحين الاخرين في
حسب بل يساعدك على تحديد ما اذا كنت ستكون
سعيدا في عملك الجديد ام لا في البدايه
يمكن توجيه هذا السؤال بثقه هل اجبت على
جميع اسئلتك او هل تريد مني توضيح اي شيء
قلته او انت قراته في سيرتي الذاتيه ومن
ثم اسال عن المشاكل او التحديات التي
تواجهها الشركه وما الخطوات المتبعه
للتقدم على ابرز المنافسين لها وكيف لي ان
اسهم في تقدم الشركه من اهم الاسئله التي
عرضها تقرير وكاله بلومبيرج ايضا هي عن
سياسه العمل من المنزل وما اذا كانت الفرص
والاجور متساويه للموظفين الذين يعملون عن
بعد والذين يعملون من المكتب ايضا من
حقيقه السؤال حول كيفيه تقييم الاداء
ومعرفه قياس الشركه لنجاح موظفيها ولكن
تجنب السؤال عن ايام الاجازات ولا تتحدث
عن الراتب حتى المراحل الاخيره في
المقابله والافضل انتظار العرض الذي سيقدم
من قبلهم
[موسيقى]
قبل ان ندخل في التفاصيل المشاهدينا وفي
النقاش حول هذا الموضوع سالنا الناس في
الاردن ما السؤال الذي تعتقد انه يجب
تطرحه انت في مقابله العمل خلونا نشوف
الاجابات
[موسيقى]
اول سؤال ممكن اطرحه الراتب بضمان
ممكن اسالهم كمان اذا ممكن اجرب الشغل
مثلا شهر انه جربوني واجربهم ممكن ما
ارتاح من الشغل هل ممكن اني مثلا معاكم
كمان عشر سنين نفترض مثلا انه يكون في
حوافز مثلا ترقيات زياده رواتب بدي اسال
اول اشي عن طبيعه الشغل شو المحفزات اللي
عندهم
التامينات اللي راح يقدم لي اياهم مثلا
الرواتب اللي
راح يعطيني من هالشغله الترقيات
[موسيقى]
الحوافز اللي راح يعطوها
التامينات اللي ممكن الواحد ياخذها
للوظيفه يعني
نظام الترقيات ونظام العلوات مثلا اذا في
مكافات هل يوجد تامين يعني في تامين ما في
تامين في مكافات بعد التقاعد ما في مكافات
التقاعد بس
[موسيقى]
اكثر من سؤال يعني مثلا قديش الراتب
سجلوا الضمان ولا لا كم عدد الساعات
بطلبوا عدم محكوميه اشياء زي هيك الوقت
الوقت يعني ضرورها ملحه انه الانسان
يستطيع من خلال يوفق بين عمله فيها وايضا
اسرته والمهام الاخرى
طب لو سالتك شنو السؤال اللي راح تطرح هنا
على الشغل الوظيفيه
طلع بس مش لازم نحكي مع الراتب الا في
الاخر انا سؤال الوحيد براسي حتى لا يحسون
اني انا ميت على الوظيفه انت راح اقدم
استقالتي لازم
بعد ما اشتغل حتى لما يرفضوني انا ابعث
لهم ايميل اني انا ارفض رفضكم
المستشار في تطوير الاعمال طراد صبحك الله
بالخير
وتصبحك الله بالجور والسرور قبل ما تسال
اي سؤال بس حابب ارحب بعوضه المخضرمين
راويه الثقافه
والمغامر ابو المحاربين الحمد لله الحمد
لله لنا جميعا
الله يحفظك يا رب ويحفظ لك عيالك واحبابك
يطول لي عمرك شكرا جزيلا يا طراد طراد
دائما الواحد اذا راح وظيفه يكون خايف من
انه ما يقبل لكن بالفعل كما قالت دراسه
حتى لا يظهر انه انا ميت عليكم ترى ما
عندي الا انتم من ما هو السؤال الابرز
اللي من الممكن انه تطرحه على
شؤون الموظفين او اللقاب لك
وبالعكس لما اسال هذه الاسئله تعطي وجهه
نظري انه انا انسان يوافق ويكون ملفت عن
جميع الاخرين الصامتين اللي بس على قولك
هيموتوا على الوظيفه انا جهزت اربعه اسئله
على الموظف وشاب جي بي تي ساعدني في
ثلاثيه الشركه في شيء تساله على الشركه
الموظف يقول لك مهمتي ومكاني مستقبلي
وتطويري يعني ايش مهمتي اذا انت تبغى لي
مقدم برامج
تقول لي تعال سجل اعلانات تعال سوي تغطيات
ميدانيه
واضح جميل جدا النقطه الثانيه مكاني في
ناس عندهم ضيف توحد مثلي انا ما احب
الازعاج ما احب الاصوات العاليه فين
المكان اللي حاشتغل فيه يناسبني هل المكان
بيئه خارجيه ميدانيه ام بيئه مكتبيه اذا
مكتبيه هل هي مشتركه ولا مكاتب مغلقه
تحتاج تعرفها للموضوع يناسبك ولا لا
هذا المكان زي ما قال واحد من اللي جابوا
الاسئله قال بيئه العمل
جدا مهم العامل الثالث وهو المسار الوظيفي
يعني هذه ثلاثيه على دراسه على موظفين
الخليج قبل الرواتب يسالوا عن هذه
الثلاثيه هل انا معك فين حكون يعني
الوظيفه هذه الى متى هل في كارير ف عندك
وخطط لي عليه يعني في اشياء اهم من الراتب
طبعا لانه انا ممكن لو جاتني عرض وظيفي
براتب اغلى وانا عارف انه في شركتي هذه
خلال سنتين ثلاث سنوات ساصل الى اعلى من
العرض الوظيفي اللي جاني حاصبر انا ابغى
اجلس معاك انت وعدتني انه هذا الكريم فلان
حقي واخر شيء موضوع قلنا مهنتي ومكاني مهم
مستقبلي وتطويري مهما كنت في اجمل وظيفه
في الحياه اذا لم تتطور حتمل وتبدا تدخل
في الروتين وحتحس نفسك متضايق يعني لازم
اكون عارف فين حوصل ساعدنا في ثلاثيه
الاخرى شركه تسال عنها في الشركه ضدها
الشركه حاسال عن رؤيه الشركه لما تقول لي
والله الشركه هذه تبغى تكون افضل شيء في
المدينه اللي انا فيها طب انا انسان طموح
ابغى اكون في شركه طفله للعالميه فاذا كنت
في مكان خاطئ ولا
ما انت حتلاقي نفسك مليت وعندك افكار
وعندك احلام وما حد يساعدك النقطه الثانيه
في موضوع كيف تقيمني زي ما قال في التقرير
الاستاذ احمد كيف كيف تقيمني يعني انا
جالس اسوي برامج واس
وي مدري ايش وهم يقولوا احنا نبغى نخفض
عدد الخارجين اللي بيستقيلوا الخفض مثلا
الرواسب هل انا قادر اني احقق هذه الهدفين
ولا لا عشان لا اجلس انشغل في اشياء انا
افكرها صحيحه في النهايه تطلع خطا الحاجه
الثالثه زي ما تفضل في التقرير ايش اهداف
الشركه لهذا العام ممكن الاهداف انهم
يدخلوا على صندوق الاستثمارات انا اعرف
شخص ننقل استثمارات ممكن اتوصل اتواصل
معاه واحقق هدف الشركه ويكون كبير طب يا
تراب وين نقطه التوازن ما بين اني اسال
اسئله
تبينني انه انا انسان واثق في مقابله عمل
وما بين الجانب الاخر من هيك اني اكون
ملحه كتير بالاسئله ازعج الشخص اللي عماله
بيعمل لي انترفيو وبالتالي اخليه ممكن
يصرف النظر عني انه هذا شخص راح يوجع لي
راسي
جميل جدا الكلمات يعني ممكن احد ياخذ
الاسئله هذه ويروح يسويها كانه بيعمل
تحقيق مع الشخص ما ينفع الكلمات اثرها 8%
اللغه او نبره الصوت حاجه وثلاثين في
المئه تقريبا الجزء الاكبر لغه الجسد لما
انا اوري الناس شفته قبل شويه تح
لل والملكه والامراء الفكره كيف انه كيف
جلسه اتكلم هل انا متحمس ما في احد يبغى
يشوف شخص جا على رجل وماسكلي ايش هو
مصارفكم الوظيفه الكبير لما يجي يقول
ممتاز طب يعني هل في كرير فلان معين موجود
في شركه ابغى ابين انا قديش متحمس لانه
هذا الحماس الشخص اللي جالس يشوفك الان هو
جالس يشوفك بخياله معاه في المكتب فهل انت
حتكون الشخص اللي يعطي هذه الطاقه للمكان
ويرفع الشركه ويرفع اداء المكان كله
شكرا جزيلا لك طبعا كان معنا مشاهدينا
المستشار في تطوير الاعمال طراد سمبل من
جده يعطيك الف عافيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات